je crois que la réponse est dans votre
question je m'associe à tous vos
arguments d'abord c'est vrai et je l'ai
dit et je le disais d'ailleurs bien
avant ma nomination comme ministre de la
Culture nous avons besoin d'un
audiovisuel public puissant ça c'est une
réalité je sais aussi monsieur le
Président puisque nous avons eu quelques
échanges que nous partageons plusieurs
convictions sur ce sujet alors
l'adoption et vous l'avez rappelé en
juin dernier de votre proposition de loi
relative à la réforme de l'audiovisuel
public et la souveraineté audiovisuel
évidemment en témoigne évidemment je
m'appuiererai sur ces travaux alors bien
sûr il y a votre texte mais aussi il y a
de nombreux travaux réalisés d'ailleurs
je je les ai consulté avant mes
interventions par qui ont été réalisé
par le Sénat comme le rapport des
sénateurs kucci et Hugonet publié en
2022 excellent rapport kucci
Hugonet et le rapport de 2015 des
excellents tout aussi excellents
sénateurs gâ et le le
alors alors risque du vous l'avez vous
les avez vous l'avez rappelé sur les
enjeux et cet environnement très
perturbé avec tous ces bouleversements
technologiques l'uniformisation des
contenus par les grandes plateformes
international la désinformation sur les
réseaux l'irruption de l'intelligence
artificielle tous ces enjeux là
évidemment vous les aviez intégrés alors
c'est vrai il ne faut pas se dérober et
il faut pouvoir répondre à ces en jeux
cruciaux alors moi je plaide pour un
audiovisuel public qui rassemble toutes
ses forces ça correspond évidemment à
votre texte je sais que ces attentes il
y a des attentes très fortes sur ces
sujets alors moi j'avancerai en
concertation évidemment avec vous je
m'appuierai je je le dis ici je l'avais
pas précisé auparavant je m'appuiererai
sur votre texte et sur votre PPL
monsieur le Président la fond et euh
également avec vous les sénateurs mais
aussi sans exclure euh aucun autre euh
intervenant et notamment vos collègues
députés et les grands sujet pareil nous
les aborderons de manière très précise
et de manière assumée quels sont-ils
notamment le financement du service
public de l'audiovisuel mais j'avais
déjà donné mes convictions bien avant et
je raccontrerai je vous l'ai dit les les
dirigeants de des sociétés très bientôt
et nous nous reverrons évidemment pour
lancer ses travaux ensemble et je vous
le redis on ne se dérobera
pas